hey what's up guys it's marquez from
mkbhd and this is what i see every time
someone asks me for my tech predictions
in 2012.
yup
yup mm-hmm yeah
yeah so who's in that bus you might be
wondering uh i have my big three my big
three tech companies that i think are
going to just take over in 2012 those
are google
apple and amazon i'll start with google
google in 2011 introduced of course we
all know google plus and finally
released the ice cream sandwich android
4.0 and that is uh which we see on the
galaxy nexus right here and they've been
pushing google plus to be integrated in
everything i think in 2012 google is
going to do a lot more of the same thing
they're probably going to release a
revision of ics maybe ics 4.1 but what
i'm most excited for is to see google
plus everywhere also google chrome is
kind of a big deal as you know google
chrome has been a very high growth rate
browser in the past couple months and i
think google in 2012 is going to push
those two things google plus and google
chrome for apple 2012 will be the first
year that they go through a full year
without steve jobs and i think this is
kind of a big deal for them but uh most
importantly they have some new products
to announce and to release the mac pro
hasn't been updated or refreshed or
anything in a long time so i'm looking
forward to seeing what happens with that
the ipad 3 is looking to be released
actually in the next couple months and
uh the iphone 5 or 6 or whatever they
call it it's the it's the sixth
generation but it's the fifth and la i
don't really know either way apple's got
some uh very enthusiastic audience
members to please uh and i think they're
gonna have another strong year in 2012
just like they always do now you might
have expected amazon to be in my big
three but it honestly is the third
biggest company for me as a tech
enthusiast i mean think about it when's
the last time you ordered something
online that wasn't from amazon amazon i
don't know if you know started as only
an online bookstore and now sells just
about everything and they they might
even sell groceries in 2012 who knows
their kindle fire was also ridiculously
popular in 2011 and i think that we'll
see a kindle fire to around the same
time in 2012. other than that yeah
that's that's pretty much what i see for
tech in 2012 uh just my sort of short
roundup video if you guys have any other
thoughts or if your big three would have
been different or in a different order
let me know in the comment section below
of course that's always wide open and
i'm always answering comments and a
thumbs up on this video is definitely
appreciated thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you guys through
the rest of 2012. if you're going to ces
by the way
better put up videos because i want to
see it
peace
you